[Music]
this is the huawei mate 20 pro huawei's
latest flagship phone in the mate series
the new mate 20 pro runs on the new
kirin 980 chipset which is based on the
new 7 nanometer architecture similar to
the iphone 10s its new octa-core
processor is also supplemented by a
neural processing unit for its ai
capabilities it runs on android pi 9.0
along with huawei's emui skin on top of
it there's also a non-pro version of the
mate 20
of which we'll discuss differences later
on the design of the phone is what we've
come to expect from 2018 smartphones
with curved glass on the front and rear
sandwiching and aluminium frame similar
to what we've seen from other android
phones this year the mate 20 pro comes
in three colors black the twilight from
the p20 and the new emerald green the
glass back enables for wireless charging
and this time they have incorporated a
new tag called the hyper optical pattern
basically micro ridges on the glass that
gives you extra grip on the phone
this is however only seen on the emerald
green version
with wireless charging also comes
hallway's new reverse wireless charging
it's the technology enabling you to
charge another phone with your huawei
mate 20 pro the mate 20 pro sports a
3120x1440
oled hdr display measuring 6.39 inches
there's a notch at the top and a minimal
chin on the bottom
the mate 20 pro also unlocks with a new
in-screen fingerprint sensor under the
hood the mate 20 pro has 6 gigabytes of
ram and internal storage of 128
gigabytes this is expandable up to 256
gigabytes via huawei's new nano memory
card
a nano memory card is the same size as a
nano sim and will slot into the second
sim tray as seen from the leaks the
cameras here are housed in a square
module instead of being stacked on top
of each other the triple camera system
is brought over from the p20 pro
although there are some differences
the three cameras here each cover a
different field of view
the main camera has 40 megapixels with a
standard field view
the 8 megapixel telephoto is carried
over from the p20
and there's a new inclusion of an ultra
wide angle lens on the third 20
megapixel camera replacing the dedicated
monochrome camera from the p20 pro
portrait mode in the camera is updated
here
apart from the usual background blur
adjustments
users are now able to change the shape
of the bokeh produced and have multiple
portrait lighting options available
there are a slew of ai features that
huawei is boasting with their camera
technology the most useful one being
high vision
in which the ai is able to identify an
object location or food that is placed
in front of it
and there's also ai-powered real-time
translation
which is very useful for travellers
although point to note is that an
internet connection is required for
these to work
with all this performance the mid 20 pro
has a massive
4200 milliamp hour battery to keep it
running
based on what i've tested the phone has
no problem lasting all day
in order to charge this huge battery
huawei is introducing their supercharged
technology
which uses a 40 watt charger to charge
this phone
there's an obvious lag of a headphone
jack and if you notice there are no
speaker grilles as well this phone is
rated for ip68 water and dust resistance
and it employs a new invisible speaker
design which uses the usb-c port at the
bottom as the speaker outlet now we're
going to discuss the differences between
the mate 20 pro and the mid 20.
so the mate 20 is a lower spec version
but it sports a larger 6.59 lcd display
with a dual drop notch at the top with
the cheaper display option it also does
not support an in-screen fingerprint
sensor there's no glass back on this one
so there is no wireless charging
capability the triple camera system
remains on the mid 20 but the camera
resolutions have some slight differences
battery size is also reduced to 4 000
milliamp hours instead of 4200 and
charging will be slightly slower with a
22.5 watt charger instead the headphone
jack sees a place on the mid 20 but this
removes its ip68 water and dust
resistance do read our article on the
key differences between the mate 20 and
mate 20 pro in the link below
the new huawei mate 20 and huawei mate
20 pro will be available in singapore on
27 october onwards and a recommended
retail price of 998 dollars and
1348 dollars respectively with the mate
20 and mate 20 pro hallway is raising
the bar on performance expected from its
smartphones and considering the slightly
disappointing releases from their
competitors hallway might be the new
leader in the smartphone market
[Music]
you